Loop quantum gravity, the theory on which
I work is a mathematical description of the
quanta of err space, a quanta of space-time.
Um the… err… you can think of the elementary
chunk of space. The Plank size elementary
bits out of which space is in their quanta.
Um… They’re linked to one another, and
there are all these links and you follow these
links and you close and make a loop. That’s
where the name Loop Quantum Gravity comes
from.
The key point, the crucial point, is that you have
to think of these bits, these quanta of gravity,
not as things immersed in space. It’s not
space and these quanta here and there. They
are space itself. They made up space themselves.
So what we call space is a collection of these
connected to one another. And what we call
distance is sort of numbering of how many
of these; what we call time is how they transform
into one another continuously. The number
of steps in this transformation.
So these are quanta. But they’re not like
particles. They’re not particles in particle
physics, the quanta of the field. The photons
are the quanta of the electromagnetic field.
But the photons are little chunks of energy
that travel in space. While the quanta of
gravity are little chunks of gravity, of something,
um which make them, made up themselves of
space, but they don’t live in space.
Like this is the constant, my analogy… if
you look at my t-shirt, it’s not that my
t-shirt has threads in it, if you take away
the threads, it’s not a t-shirt still there.
There is nothing. So the t-shirt is just weaved
by the threads.
So space itself is weaved by this interconnected
quanta of gravity. This is the core of loop
quantum gravity.